what I hope to do in this videos is
hopefully give you some clarity on terms
that you might hear used in a fairly
related way and those are the terms gene
and allele gene vs. allele so let's do a
little bit of review let's just reorient
ourselves in the world of DNA and RNA
let's say that this this yellow squiggly
line is a length of let us say my DNA
and let's say this little white section
right over here that's if we were to
zoom in and we've represented the
various base pairs and this the sequence
of base pairs is really the information
content in DNA and here I've just kind
of drawn it as a as a ladder but we know
that the real structure of DNA is it's
kind of a twisted ladder this this this
double helix now if we talk about this
this whole yellow squiggly line and it
could be even a section of a longer
yellow squiggly line this could code for
multiple for multiple things especially
multiple proteins so different regions
of this could code for different
proteins so for example this section
right over here could be part of this
region that I'm highlighting in blue
that codes for a specific protein and so
we would call this a gene we would call
this a gene this might be a protein that
is involved in I don't know I'll make
something up it's a protein that's of
all involved in the immune system maybe
maybe this stretch let me do it in a
different color
maybe this stretch of DNA right over
here
this stretch of DNA maybe it's a longer
stretch of DNA maybe it codes it codes
for a protein that's used maybe it maybe
it's a protein that helps regulate DNA
replication maybe over here is another
we encode for another protein that now
may be a maybe it in some ways effects
affects the pigmentation of your skin or
the pigmentation of your eyes and so you
have these stretches of DNA that code
for specific things and actually it
doesn't have to just even be for a
protein we've always talked about even
if you do code for a protein you go from
the DNA to messenger RNA to messenger
RNA next you can you
goto pre messenger RNA and that that
that gets processed so you can actually
can lose some sections of it but you go
to messenger RNA and then that messenger
RNA every three every three of these
base pairs is a codon let me let me so
let's say that's one codon one two three
that's another codon
one two three each of those and maybe
I'll draw them next to each other each
of them codes for an amino acid that is
kind of connected together to form
connect it together to form a protein so
that's one amino acid right over there
this could be another amino acid right
over there and now we're going to see we
can keep going on and on and on you can
have another amino acid right over here
and then they all bond to each other and
they're brought actually to the mRNA
from by a functional RNA group and so
there are functional things other than
proteins that this could go for like
trna T RNA which is really helping to
transport the appropriate amino acids to
the mRNA in in in the ribosome so that
you can construct these proteins so you
could have tRNA and we've seen this
before in previous videos it's this
little squiggly line matches up to the
appropriate codon and then puts that
amino acid in place you also have things
like ribosomal RNA that make up the
structure of the actual ribosome so RNA
doesn't only have to play this kind of
in between messenger function it
actually can play a functional or a
structural role in fact there are
theories that the earliest life the most
primitive life was nothing but
self-replicating RNA and then the
systems became more and more and more
complicated and more complex and until
eventually you end up with things like
redwood trees and hippopotami
hippopotamuses hippopotami what
elephants well whatever else but it all
started with potentially
self-replicating RNA some people say
might be some type of proteins that were
able to replicate who knows but RNA is
definitely is definitely an interesting
character in this so you go from gene to
RNA that's transcription and then RNA to
protein to protein that is translation
but sometimes you just stop at the RNA
and the RNA by itself
plays a functional
functional RNA so each of these genes
they can they can code for type of
protein or even a functional RNA that's
what a gene is now what about an allele
when the allele is a specific variation
of the gene so for example let's say
that you look at the at the same stretch
of DNA let's say this is my DNA and if I
were to take your DNA out and if I would
look on the same chromosome at the same
region where both human beings and we
have for the most part very similar DNA
so this is actually let me let me
straighten it out so let's say this is
my DNA a section of my DNA and let's say
this right over here this in Y it is a
section of your DNA and so if we look at
that gene that blue gene that's that on
my DNA now if we look at that and this
is the blue gene this is the blue gene
on your DNA
now we're both human beings and most of
our genetic material is fairly similar
but we might have variations in how this
gene is coded for example you might have
or I might have a let's say I have a an
adenine right there but right at that
exact spot you might have a different
base you might have a I don't know you
might have a you might actually let me
just you might have a you might have a
thymine right over there
so it's encoding for a protein or even a
functional RNA that's playing the same
role maybe it has a role in the immune
system role in your skin color a role in
how your brain develops but there is a
variation there's a variation in how its
coded now some of these variations which
could arise through mutations it might
not have any impact in the function of
the eventual protein that gets
constructed you might just have a
different amino acid someplace in fact
you might not even have a different
amino acids because many times you have
two codons coding for the same amino
acid but even in a case you might have
one different amino acid in a protein
that has 4,000 amino acids and it
doesn't change how that that protein
acts or how it functions or sometimes it
might it might change how that protein
functions it might change how that
protein regulates other things and
whoever knows whatever else and so you
can imagine that you have genes this
gene right over here maybe it has a role
in eye color and because of this
variation or because of other variations
said that show up in both cases they
code for the protein that say regulates
eye color or regulates the amount of
pigment you have but because your
variation right over here might lead or
help Li then these things are very
complex it's very seldom that you just
have a gene for this but this might make
you especially if you have a gene like
this from both of your parents maybe
this one would go for blue eyes blue
eyes it somehow helps produce blue eyes
while this while mine somehow helps
produce brown eyes and obviously I'd
want to think about which with the very
the variant of this gene that I get from
my mother and the variant of this gene
that I get from my father we all have
two copies in our in our regular somatic
cells in our body cells we have except
for if we think about the you know the
the X X and the X Y chromosomes the
sex-determining chromosomes on all of
the other chromosomes we have two copies
of the same genes we just have two we
it's just they're different variants one
variant from your mother one variant
from your father or you could say that
they are different alleles so alleles
are just different variants so these are
two different alleles they coat they're
the same gene they're the gene that
somehow deals with eye color but they're
different variations for that gene so
the gene you're speaking generally to
that region of DNA that region of the
DNA strand that in that codes for some
functional molecule usually protein but
it could be RNA while the allele is that
specific variation that flavor of that
gene hopefully that helps